in this video i'm going to explain to
you how you can get paid for your
business
tax-free
without giving up any equity
so hi if you're new to the channel my
name is alex shimozzi i own
acquisition.com in a portfolio of
companies that is about 85 million a
year and i have nothing to sell you
i just made this channel because a lot
of people are broke and i do not want
you to be one of them so welcome to mozi
nation so today the topic is going to be
talking about debt and this is going to
be one of the more
interesting chats we've had because this
is something that i have spent a lot of
time learning about and probably not in
the traditional sense of like you know
personal finance but more so in the kind
of mergers and acquisition sense of how
debt is used right and so one of the
first things that i had to understand
what as like as a business owner is
understanding why we want to sell a
business because a lot of people want to
exit their business because it seems
like this big aspirational goal and as
somebody who has now exited six
different businesses i can tell you it's
not nearly as inspiring there's the
story of the exit and there's the
reality of the exit the reality of exit
is that you've got transition documents
not all of that cash is up front most of
the time you're gonna have earn outs
you're gonna have seller financing
that's involved you have to roll a
certain percentage of equity and you've
got uh and then finally you've got cash
once you have cash you have bonuses
distributions you've got uh financing
costs that are associated with the act
transaction costs and then finally you
have your chunk of money but wait
there's another 20 that's going to go to
uncle sam and then you're left with x
right and sometimes x is very different
from the enterprise value of what you've
sold out
and so
one of the things that i can tell you
about the wealthiest people that i know
who are all over 10 figures is that the
wealthiest people in the world they buy
and they build and most times they don't
sell even though us as entrepreneurs we
have this dream of it it's usually
because we're trying to get out of some
sort of pain right because
i have realized this that the times that
i want to sell is when i'm in the most
pain the times when i don't want to sell
is when i everything's uh going well and
so what i should be doing is figuring
out how to get out of pain rather than
trying to you know it's like there's i
think there's a chinese saying
to kill a mosquito with a cannon right
which is like it's overkill it's like
hey why don't we just solve the problem
by hiring the one or two people you need
to hire rather than sell the entire
business right and so one of the things
i want to introduce today along that
concept is how can you still get paid or
de-risk
because for most business owners or
entrepreneurs the majority of your net
worth is in your business right and so
or businesses and so if the majority of
your net worth is in this thing that's a
high-risk asset class i'd like to
ideally
share uh some of that risk with other
people and so there are multiple
different debt functions you can use but
i think the easiest analogy for this is
a house okay or an apartment building
doesn't really matter so let's imagine
you have a house and let's imagine that
you started this except this house
you were able to build without land
and you were able to build it just using
your own money and you actually built it
yourself all right so you paid money out
of pocket month over month over month
and you slowly started assembling this
house piece by piece by piece right and
then you started getting tenants inside
of it right you got little tenants in
here
and you know for us those are our
customers but it functions more or less
the same way you got these people that
you you've been slowly filling it up and
so now all of a sudden this thing spits
out cash flow every month just like a
rental you know apartment unit might the
similarity here and i'm using this
analogy because it was the one that made
the most sense to me is that
everything up to this point you own 100
in cash all right this is equity that
you have in this house now in a normal
home or you're a real estate investor
you would say hey i would like to get
higher returns because i can get all you
know 80 of this financed through a bank
right you can get a loan in the form of
debt and so the example here is let's
say you've got a one million dollar uh
business you've got a one million dollar
business right which we'll still use is
this house right
if this business over the next five
years goes to two million dollars a year
right or two million dollars in value
excuse me then you would have 2xed
your net worth right because you own 100
of this thing
now
what if you were able to have your 1
million dollar thing and then split it
into you keep 20 in the business
right and then you get a check
for 800 000
now realistically i'll tell you what the
the more realistic outcome of something
like this might be
uh and there are two ways to do this but
let's say that you did uh
30 and then 70 right so then this would
be 300k
and this would be 700k okay
so that's that's what we would get so
this would be 70 and this would be a
loan
now here's what's cool
because this is a loan against your
building
this is not income
which means you guessed it
it's tax free
so remember before i talked to you
earlier if you were to sell a business
you probably have to keep a certain
percentage in because no one's going to
you know just most people are not going
to want you to have a full exit
especially if you're a smaller business
and so you would have this 80 but then
this 80 would then get nixed and cut
it's not going to be all cash anyways
but even if it were all cash you then
have to pay 20
right of that of that amount which would
be 16 off um from whatever that number
is which you know for math sake let's
you get 760k but you have to take the 20
out so you have 560k after taxes and
with you holding your 20. so this is
what you'd get but here's what's crazy
is that through debt
you can get a seven hundred thousand
dollar loan and still own the darn thing
but here's what's cooler you now have
your one million dollar business that's
growing to two million dollars for
example but then you have this this
seven hundred thousand dollars that you
have a loan from off of this that you
can also still try and grow you know
let's say two million dollars in that
same time period and now you own the
delta which overall your net net worth
is now 3.3 million versus the original 2
million you had before
and so
there are two ways there's a lot of ways
that you can you can take out a debt in
the company you can do minority you can
do majority you can do dividend recap
there's more things that that i can get
into but fundamentally just
understanding that from an exit
perspective this changed the way i saw
business is that if you don't want to
sell because you want to keep your thing
forever
totally fine but as you're keeping it
it's just like an apartment building you
can still refinance
at regular intervals as the as the value
of the property or as your business
grows
so that you can then then excuse me take
this money out de-risk yourself and put
it in other assets because let's be real
we have all been through a crazy last
couple years
anything could happen and so for you to
de-risk a little bit um i think for many
is a beneficial thing and candidly it's
also how every ceo of a publicly traded
company lives is they don't they never
sell their equity or some of them but
majority of the time they're not selling
their equity they're living off of loans
that are asset based they loan against
the equity that they have and the the
stocks grow
tax free because they compound
and then the loans are locked in which
you can then refinance them later
because now the asset is worth more and
so you basically just gained that money
for truly for you don't even have to pay
it back uh or even if it was uh the same
price overall you actually still got a
discount because you didn't have to pay
income tax on the loans you took against
your assets right and so um i wanted to
explain this because in my mind i didn't
know a way to uh to to have any kind of
de-risking event for myself without
selling the business
uh i just didn't know if there was
another way and so i'm making this like
i make everything in this channel is
because a lot of people are broke and i
know which one of them and i've learned
you know a fair amount in the in the
transactions that we've done and growing
the companies that we have and i just
want to share those lessons to you guys
so hopefully enjoy this hopefully this
is a frame shift or perspective in terms
of how you see the equity uh growth in
your business how you ultimately can can
grow your net worth faster in a lower
risk environment um that way and i'll
tell you one more thing i was talking to
a private equity
managing partner and he was saying how
for some of our companies for example he
was like you guys don't even have uh you
have you have negative leverage he said
you have cash on your balance sheet he's
like it's ridiculous he said you should
be
taking loans against that equity so that
you can redeploy it and and do x y and z
and so uh it was just a very interesting
perspective i thought i would share it
with you um it's something that we look
to uh you know continue to do uh in our
businesses and i figured i would share
it with you because i love you guys and
keeping awesome so enjoy this video
enjoy the next video and i'll see you
soon bye